From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, let me start with just this announcement.
My name is Joe Manier of the Southern, and my mic, the Pierre-Choyan.
A Southern oral history program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm in New York City and Midtown, or I guess lower Midtown or...
Yes, this is West Side. West...
Well, the Flatiron District, I think it's for these on the east side.
Technically a little east of us.
I'm with videographer John Bishop, and we are here to do an oral history interview for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
And we're just delighted and very honored today to be with Ms. Gloria Hayes' Danridge to talk about all of the work Ms. Danridge that you did and have done over the years in the movement.
So thank you very much for coming to sit down with us today. We appreciate it.
Let me, I think in our hour, hour and a half that we can spend together day in conversation.
I thought I would start just having to talk a little bit about your experience of that Howard, where you enrolled in 1938, I think.
Yes. I went to Howard. My cousins had been there before me, and so it was kind of like...
I was young, I think I was like fairly 16. And for me, it was comfortable knowing my cousins, you know, I come up with for there.
But I went to Howard, and I think that first year, they said I was shy, but I think it was just a lot going on, and I come from a small town, my first time away from home.
But it worked out well in terms of friendships, and then my family knew people in Washington, they had children there.
I happened to have gone there when they had some really great minds, and I get...
I don't, I have no sense of what they would be now, but then we're considered very radical.
And, you know, they published Franklin Frazier, and I was a tripping class because he thought I was too shy, naive.
And he was always explaining his wrong to your comments to me and embarrassing me in front of the class.
But anyhow, and Rayford Logan, so it was a good time, and we did...
My first demonstration really was there, first against the university because of a curve views and things.
And secondly, there...
And I'm a little confused about what organizations started at, but we did some demonstrations.
I think against Woolworths, probably in my junior year.
So I went through that, and came out and graduated, worked in the government, took a government exam, worked in the government for a couple of years.
Now, I want to ask a little bit more about your how it years.
You have written that you've protested at Woolworths, and I think that was picketing rather than...
Oh, yes, no, it was picketing.
But you... I'm really interested in how your perspective was emerging as a young adult in those years on.
And you've also mentioned your protest on campus over curfews, which was kind of related to the gender notion of women's rules on campus.
That's true, it's true and right.
It was, it was, yeah.
And what was your sense of the world you wanted to create the world you wanted for yourself as a woman as an African-American?
I don't think I thought of creating a world. I think I was just passing through it.
I knew I had to make the craze, you know, I had friendships there.
I think that it was other people around me that convinced me to go on these demonstrations of picketing.
And I went along.
Because even the movement people were writing me saying, is this...
Are you sure you're the same, very shy, you know, girl woman that was at...
Are you sure that's who you are?
And so I guess I've been projecting, probably was.
Because when I... The first press conference, when they're outside press can, they had pushed me out to do my eyes.
And the only reason why I did it was because I was the only one there that they said they wanted one voice through which to speak.
But I had a good time at Howard and I learned a lot.
I think because these professors were radical, you know, that came through their lectures.
E. Franklin Frazier was really against what he called the Black Dwarfs, where I see it.
And some of those people... Some of those models, you know, I had come across with my family and their relationships in various towns across the East Coast.
Sure. Let me ask what I want to ask about your family.
And if you could situate your family in Cambridge, I know that's a long story.
No, it's not a long story, but I...
Well, I guess actually, although I wasn't raised that way, I guess they were in terms of the Black community, the first family in Cambridge.
My grandfather had been on the City Council for years.
He wasn't the first Black man. I think there were two other Black people that had been in the City Council.
And he was the third.
We didn't really know until my cousin's not. We were married.
It had children that we were supposed to have been wealthy.
I can imagine going downtown and he was segregated and saying, oh, I don't know which sweat he couldn't try at home.
I don't know. I like that sweater, but we can't afford it.
And the clerk's saying to me, why don't you go home and ask your parents if you can afford it?
Because I think they knew better than he did.
And because we were in business, you had to speak to everybody or every sports or every street.
And it became almost automatic.
My grandfather was not particularly religious, but he gave money and land and stopped to the church.
My grandmother, in the winter because we had seasonal workers or seasonal work rather, then the packing companies would send food out in the red cross, all segregated with send whatever clothing they had.
And the grandmother would distribute that sometimes by going out into the poor communities and sometimes from our house.
I think we mainly were in the family. Most of the family houses were within a block of each other and you ran back and forth.
My grandfather was in system that you come back and help the town and the community.
And I think most of us did.
Yeah, you moved back after that.
Come and join me mentioned and family.
Can you describe the basic arrangements in Cambridge, racial geography of Cambridge?
It was in the late 50s.
It had been, it was totally segregated.
The shopping, there was one room reserved in the hospital, one maternity room.
And of course, if they got overloaded with white people, then that went.
And so you had to be in all.
I think they used my grandfather for, you know, should you give this person credit.
And in terms, he got a lot of people out of the Merlin Pena Tentry and the J.O.'s and stuff.
Even though he sent on the council when they had their annual banquet,
they would infuriate my grandmother.
They would bring the meal out to him.
Because he was not allowed to join them.
Don't join them, that's right.
So in that respect, I was, and that's true of Washington too.
So that was true my life, however, within that framework.
And because I guess we were restricted to one ward, then your daily life was within the confines of that.
People that had to go outside of that bubble and work, that was a different thing.
I just probably fully realized some of that when I just read the book, The Help,
out of Mississippi during the 60s.
And it didn't occur to me.
It occurred to me that they didn't treat, may not treat their health well.
It didn't occur to me that they would have separate bathrooms.
I mean, I just did not imagine that.
When I read it, I believed it.
But I did not conceive of that.
I think Black folks in that town, and people wonder why Cambridge.
But I think their history there, they were, and I don't understand this at all.
My grandfather was in the census when he was 12 years old, was in school.
And I was told where, and they said, in school.
But they were also slaves there.
So there seemed to be a combination of slave, how I, you know, I don't understand that.
I know that during a movement, very elderly people told me that at one time people in Cambridge intermarried.
And then something happened.
It was a total separation.
I don't know whether anything to do with the Civil War or whatever.
But at that time, I'm sorry now I wasn't having these conversations with the older people by family,
but I didn't care at that point.
So I think I grew up probably in a protective atmosphere,
although knowing that all of that was going on.
And the foundry, yeah, dividing white and black Cambridge and...
It was in the charter.
Yep, and was race street.
Yes.
And I have read that...
And until the movement that didn't occur to me.
I think the people that came and started saying, the street, you can't go beyond race, it's called race street.
And I thought, well, yeah, that's true.
I always thought, because they used to have, uh, sookies and things, right, racing up and down.
Right. Right.
The black community in Cambridge around 1960, I think it was about 4,000 people.
And at that time, I wonder if you recall one of the aspects of segregation in Cambridge
that would be so terribly consequential for your family was the health care and opportunities for health care.
Oh, yes, and I think so.
And the doctors did not have privilege, but doctors did not have privileges.
I mean, hospital privileges.
But your father and your uncle, I'm thinking about it.
My father had a drug store.
My cousin, Carol, was a doctor.
But he didn't have hospital privileges.
If he did, it must have been the late after I was grown.
But I know that that was an issue.
I think the doctor that came in after him did, and that was a big thing.
Oh, you can take your hospital, you don't have to go through another doctor.
The doctors, they had separate white doctors, they had separate waiting rooms for you.
Most of the time in our family, we went to Baltimore to the Provident Hospital there.
My father had started out there.
He used to be the drugist's crops.
And I think Carol did his internship there.
But usually we try to get the Provident.
Some people in their family went to John Hopkins, but the thing was Hopkins at that time.
And I guess the book on Henry at Locke's, which I have not read,
probably proves that because some of us in the family just thought they were using glasses any pigs.
They too had separate medical facilities.
When did your father have his heart attack?
I don't know. I think now he's rest sometimes in his 50s.
I'm very bad with years.
But he did, but no, but he couldn't not go to the hospital.
Because I guess of whatever kind of respect they had for my grandfather,
one of the white doctors came to the hospital.
We wanted to move him to Provident Hospital, but by that time it was too late.
But he worked very hard to 12 and 1 o'clock.
Not only the prescriptions, but patent medicines and a full range of, I guess, like to any of these stuff.
And the soda fountain.
In 1960, you were running the store?
Yes, he had died.
I don't remember during that time, but at times we had problems of finding a black pharmacist
that wanted to come into a small town.
And in the meantime, Craig's jokes still, the white track still filled that prescriptions for us.
And was very helpful, in fact.
What did you, what was your feeling about your role running that store and being in that position?
Did you enjoy that work? Did you?
Well, I used to have excursions that came from Baltimore.
And hundreds of people would come.
My grandfather would get, they would accept Craig.
I was down by the war.
And they would eat crabs and things, and they'd come uptown and go into the house home.
And buy stuff.
So I used to have to sell little things, cosmetics and things, and help out, you know, along the way.
Both there, and then my grandfather's grocery store.
But that was kind of because I was just really devastated about my father.
And it was difficult getting people to come in and manage the jokes.
My then husband, my father had been sending him to how pharmacy school was in F.D. Diody.
That just kind of went all right.
I don't think he was real interested.
Tell me about W. You mentioned before we started today.
But it was a good place to hear what everybody in the community thought was the freedom rights and the movement started.
And I can carry information back and forth.
And actually, the freedom rights and the SNCC field workers had been there almost a month before, in my uncle's house,
before I knew anything about it.
Because I was working at the 12th clock and coming home.
And to one day they came and said that my uncle said that I had a daughter and that a lot of people, her age gathered there on Saturdays to make cookies.
And so I said, sure, you can go back and ask them.
And that was the beginning of it.
So I wanted some local guys to take them around the community, went on the weekends.
And that was December, I think, late 61 by then.
Late 61 running over into January.
You mentioned that you sort of began in that first phase as an observer and students in younger folks, including your daughters.
Oh, yes, they would have what they called the observer so that they would have somebody that if something went wrong, you know, that was seasoned enough, you know, to say what went on right or wrong and to, you know, the worn people.
And then once or twice, I went on the, I went on the picket to mine.
I finally decided to do that.
And my daughter had to put me off the picket line because for whatever reason, as a grown woman, I thought I could, you know, walk some kind of way and trip these people that were spitting at you and stuff.
That's going down.
And she put me off because you were not.
My mom get off.
Because she didn't see you hearing perfectly.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
No, she did.
Yeah.
So I thought, well, I don't think I'm cut out for this.
So, yeah, tell me a little about how you were drawn into a leadership role.
Oh, yes, they were.
They had my, my cousin, Frederick Sanklair, who had been providing with his father, the bail, as the Freedom Riders went up and down the Eastern Shore,
said to one person, what you all really need to do in the place that really needs to be fixed is Cambridge, Maryland.
So why don't you all stop off there?
So two of them did.
And then they took, yeah, they had Bill Hansen, Reginald Robinson.
So they didn't stay at my uncle's house and they started having Clawing and Community people.
And who I wasn't part of that either, that supported the young people and whatnot.
And then, Donna was involved.
She claims this is, she didn't remember this, but I had my own daughter, Donna.
She was one of the organizers, in turn, became one of the organizers of the high school students.
And so, both high school and grammar school kids, when they practically stopped the town.
And then the ministers went down and agreed that, well, if we have peace, we can't make a agree with White for.
Unless you have peace, you can't negotiate.
So one of the past, two of the past, three of these past, the parents that had gotten emotionally involved with the kids.
And that's when they had a big mass meeting and decided to send people down to SNK and ask if we could have an adult group.
And in that process, they asked me if I would take a leadership role there, because they felt at that time we weren't talking about violence.
They thought that financially, I would not be jeopardized because there would be somebody that would take care of me, my family.
And that's really, and my cousin and I went down to SNK agreed.
And we came back and started going into laundry mats, the churches, the bars, and sending out little bad, they put together newsletters and organizing throughout the county.
Let me ask you a little more about this topic.
And then initially, we're going to pause for just a second.
We'll look back. We'll back after a short break, please.
Oh, okay. You were saying.
Well, let me ask this if I could encourage that.
Oh, our first thing was on voter registration. I didn't really believe in that.
I just thought people had to be shown that because we've been voting still since 18th, one of the places on the show, that even though we voted and were hearing to all the things, still had segregated hospitals, housing, jobs to hold.
But we thought that in general, people, that had to be brought to their attention.
They may have realized that on some subterranean level, but in terms of, in their daily consciousness.
And they gradually happened. Once we picked the people and won, and they thanked us very much for our support, but it's nothing we can do about the streets and stop whatever.
Just mine or think, which you asked.
I want to take you back to that spring 62, that trip to Atlanta to go down and meet the SNCC folks.
Yes.
You've written that you went down with, I think, white gloves and a very good skirt on.
And you encountered the SNCC crew. And I'm interested in the transition from sort of that early experience to the, you would, you would very much build your own movement in Cambridge.
Yes.
I think it depends on the SNCC folks in many, when some leaders are in the...
Yeah, I don't think I'm real quite, I mean, looking back now, I can see that.
We supported them, but we had moved away from the public accommodations. People would say to me, it was just true.
Those are sleazy restaurants. I don't care what level, economic level, the person, oh, it's sleazy restaurant. What do we care about?
So, except for that you should have, you're right to go in there, should not be a bridge.
But when we did the, when we, we, uh, uh, structured the survey, and what we called Junior CNAC, which were the grandma school kids, took it, took it throughout the community, it's done, brought it back.
Volunteers from, from Swarthmore took it back to their professors and they did the, the right up in the correlation.
From those facts of cards. And then it became clear that public accommodations were really at the bottom of the list.
Housing, yes, with housing, jobs, you know, health issues. And we structured the demands around that.
Describe that so you're, you're, you want the survey, which was very, um...
Thanks to you Franklin Frazier, I took a graduate course on to him.
And I don't think he thought I had skills, but anyhow, at whatever level, you know, I learned, and we did that.
And the questions on these cards were geared in those, you know, those main issues, executive board, and to see what people said about that and how they felt about it.
Yeah, so you surveyed, you sent, I think, uh, the same children who were, high school students and others who were active in the community in the movement.
That's true. To survey cards. To survey. And it really was the more the grammar school kids, because in the summer, the high school kids were out working to have the ticking of jobs.
And your card, you had, so on the whole series of questions on the card, your priorities in the movement, your aspects about your, the condition of the house you live in, the, are you, all those things?
Yes, the, the, the plumbing, the, yeah.
So you really did a, in a sense of basic solid systematic survey of conditions in, I know. And then after they, after they, they, they, uh, wrote it up and did the correlations, it swat more.
Actually, I think that's what, I think that's what changed Robert Kennedy's mind was it was perfectly clear that it was just a busily poor people that most of the component to their main being poor regeneration was racism.
And I think he got involved more because out of his, Iris, and what they had done to the Irish when they came over that he was more sympathetic to the, to, to poverty.
Tell me about that. I want to ask you.
And so when we took that to him, and then that's when he started sending us around to, to his commission, commission, that, like, commission secretary of housing and, and, you know, various agencies that fit into that.
I think by 62, especially 63.
Yeah, just, just before and just after the agreement was signed.
Yeah. Yeah.
And of course weaver, we've been a friend of our mother said, we aren't, we, we're, we're doing the house.
But as long as you all are in the streets, we are going to put a shovel in the ground.
So that was, we didn't promise that we wouldn't be in the streets because we hit us two kids in the, in the West and sure.
But, and of course passing the law to segregated housing.
Let me ask about, I want to, I want to get all the more close to tale about this because it's just so interesting.
One part of the reality of lives for many people in, in Black community, in Cambridge was housing was so poor that I think many people refer to it as, as, that the phrase was used chicken cups.
No, they were actual chicken cups.
Yeah, they have.
Oh, I mean, that may, I may have totally blanked. They were chicken cups.
Like, you know, and one on top of another and people were living in them.
And then, and I forget the names, their wife also collecting rent on it.
And I think your survey showed unemployment in the Black community.
Oh, 60%.
Yes. Well, if someone was that today.
Oh, you just aggregate the figures.
Yes.
It was high. But, but no. And that was even seasonal work.
And, and, and because the city council except for one guy.
And the aristocrats in town, you know,
had very low opinion of Black folks.
And it was, it was Grahamville, hope, or who owned the whole fuel complex.
That he eventually lost for being trying to be fair.
And they tried to, they, they are the city ordered him not to send his fuel trucks out that one.
And he said, if he had to get the Maryland State Police, he would send them out under guard.
Because all the Black folks only worked part of their time in the year.
They caught up with their bills with him when they worked.
And of course, when we, when we had the urban renewal thing,
the first thing the city of fathers did was tear down his, you know, his, his business.
Let me take you to the question I found.
How after the survey, your relationship would have, would evolve with, say, folks at SNCC and at the NAACP.
And you knew what your community's goals were.
You would build a local movement.
But oftentimes there were pressures from, especially from, say, NAACP leaders.
Oh, yeah. Well, we just ignored them after a while.
By the, by the time they decided that they weren't going to sport this or that,
people in Cambridge, you know, had solidified and can, it didn't really matter.
Because they were, they, they were trying to push ahead and until the,
see, people's strength. In the beginning, you know, they were helpful.
And I really think that's because in those first weeks, when SNCC came in,
they went around and, and urged people to join the NAACP and have the memberships.
Then there was a period of time when, when people thought if you got in trouble with the law and when jail,
you could, because you were a member of the NAACP, you could ask one of their lawyers to come down and represent you.
No, no, no, no. Because NAACP was to class contest in the first place.
They didn't want to represent anybody unless, are they middle class?
Well, what did they mother or father do? So that was out.
I think almost everyone, they brought me up here to a concert at Carnegie Hall.
Because Martin was supposed to convince me on the referendum initiative to vote.
So unfortunately, although I like Frank Sinatra and then you know, horn, I hate to leave because I was fast losing it.
And it's not that we didn't go out and support the Southern movement to get out of the vote.
But they tried a lot of stuff. I got letters from people with a few black folks that worked in the Maryland government.
You know, wrong, please reconsider this, the daughter-daw offered the governor wanted to back me as a senator,
which I would say, which I was not interested in in first place.
And, and, and a variety of things.
All these efforts have deflected you from your leadership role.
Yes. And I think Miss Judd's became Bruce Movement.
Right. Let's pause for just a sec.
We're back on that, John. I think you want to be a mention that we're now recording without the cards.
Correct. Okay.
Mr. Anders, let me, you had mentioned the pattern of efforts to sort of deflect you from your leadership role in Cambridge.
Because Cambridge had been so close to Washington DC, if it comes such a very, very active movement, a lot of national press coverage.
So there were job offers. There was this.
Oh, yeah. I forgot that. That's true. From the feds.
The federal government offered you jobs, the state government offered you jobs.
I offered it back before as a state senate candidate. They brought you to Carnegie Hall and had Frank Sinatra and Lena and other folks try to...
No, not them, but they had Martin.
Yes. Martin, the guy from Johnson's guy from Texas Hobart Taylor.
Yes.
And that all puts me in mind of how rooted the movement was in Cambridge and how thoroughly well organized the community was in support of the movement in Cambridge.
And I've read that you've written that there were probably 10 and 2014 core members who helped throughout the community that had come together as the heart of Sinatra.
That's right. It was probably on my grandfather's model, whoever the leader was in every neighborhood or who exactly, you know, people looked up to.
Yeah. So you were the man or woman.
Right. And I wanted to ask about back point and the county.
Right. So you found the people in all these different neighborhoods, cross-black community and county.
I don't know whether found is a good word. I think I knew because came to just why I knew they were always there.
I'm very interested in your experience at the head of the movement as a woman in relation to your fellow movement leaders in relation to communities that press.
Actually, I think in the first place, I was the only grandchild for a long time. Black folks had to use whatever they had.
So within my family, there was no sense of you can't do this because your woman can't, you know, even the relationships with my grandmother and mother with the men in the family.
After that, I think that was the basis of it.
But even people in the SNCC tell me, and I think it's a silly of me.
But they say when they would mention things about, well, men aren't going to, the men aren't going to want us to do that.
That I had no concept of how that would affect your behavior.
Somebody just said that to me this year. And I can't even remember it.
I remember at some point, some lady called me from out in the Midwest and asked me, well, how are they doing that?
I can remember asking, what do you mean as a woman?
Because by that time, I think in Cambridge itself, there was, they may have been before, they may have been after.
They were not. Men went to work and came home and had to lay in the fields and around their houses, it could be fire bomb.
The women were conducting the business down in the day because that they were available.
So it was almost a divisional labor. Men went to work if something happened, the women could shoot, too.
So for that period of time, at least, I don't know what goes on now or what would be before, there was not that division.
One night when the state police were marching up and down, and I had just begun to be involved.
Women were on the street saying, if you all can beat us on Saturday night, don't you let these cops come through our community?
And they were slitting down. I thought, what?
And I think that whole thing grew. Now people like to say Cambridge was just the women's room, with that was not so.
Yeah, no. I mean, it was a division of roles by necessity.
You mentioned the necessity of black men and others at times, women, even your daughter and mother at times guarding the black community.
Oh, yeah, she did within the worst night. Yes, no.
And Donna had to go through the, as we call the, the field part, the lead into people's yards.
And because there was this secret, the men really organized themselves, secret whittles.
If she had not known that or been like me and not been able to let's whistle, then she may very well have been shot.
She was trying to make it back to, because my mother was in the house alone.
But they had, because it's a hunting country.
And so they both had been out hunting at one point or another.
And so she went up there and they got on the guns and went to see.
Let me ask about, and we were lucky because General Gilston was fair.
And once he investigated, he courted Marcel, those guys, and then he'd come in.
You referred to some national guardsmen who worked in, in, they were in a, in a different location.
Yes, and then I think we, and anyhow, yeah.
Who had come through shooting up the black men at one night and they were fired black men and others in the community fired back.
Oh, yeah, I was in the street that you did.
You could hear?
Yes, I understand. I wasn't on the pine street at that time, but they drove through shooting.
Somebody had brought some machine gun home from the army from her war wanted to, to maybe.
In any of that, they were protecting that street, but they drove through the community.
And when I was staying outside, I, I think I just recently read, but that is true.
Even people that were not involved heavily involved in the movie, you could hear the clicks.
Going down point, yes, wait, at every time they came through, they shot.
The press was in my uncle's house under the tables.
It was a bad night because in the morning at five or six o'clock, it was filled with, that smoke from Guns Ozone,
what the streets were just, fortunately nobody was, was hurt or killed.
The press was on pine street hanging out, but they had their cameras and stuff, and they caught the car coming through.
And so when Gielston asked, they told him if you subpoena us, we'll bring, you can have the pictures.
And he then caught my son, the people from.
This is the National Guard Commander in the movie.
He said, black folks and capers loved him, yes.
They think the government killed him because he didn't go to Walter Reed, something was wrong.
I think they think today, and I don't know.
And then he did his job, and he was fair.
He was going to arrest you and do whatever, but he wasn't malicious.
You've had something over all these weeks and several months, you developed something in relationship with him across this movement activity.
Yes.
And I, there's one irony, and you've touched on this and things you've written, that you were both aware separately that your phones were being tapped.
Yes, he told me, when I went back there after the rep round incident, he told me yes.
And that that's why he used to send his number two guy back and forth to see that with whatever messages and negotiations or whatever we were doing because he didn't trust.
He said they would send it all the way down to Fort Bell, but Bell were, read it, send it back, and then send it as if it's coming through normally.
Yeah.
Let me ask about your principal position in relation to the referendum on public accommodations.
That was where so much of this pressure was brought to bear on you personally and on CNAC to support a referendum.
Can you talk about that whole experience and describe that situation?
Well, we didn't ever think we were supposed to vote on whether we could go into a restaurant.
We were born here, blocks in Cambridge, you'd been there for 300 and so many years, a mixture of slave, free, freed.
They had been restricted in certain communities, but they run businesses, run churches.
In Cambridge, my grandfather's brother's set up school system.
And I think there was some self-assurance you may not get in an strictly urban area where you're working for other people.
And I forgot where I was going with this.
Oh, up to the right.
So as I said earlier, people thought most of them were greasy spoons because occasionally they did get to the city and go to a decent restaurant.
And men had just come back from fighting.
So I thought it was a normal position and so did everybody else.
Except the NAACP court, the Baltimore Ministers, is this everybody outside of Cambridge.
And I don't know whether it was because they were pressured and thought against the deep south that it made more sense.
But we never were pushing that.
I just saw in the crisis, I didn't know it was on the internet.
The article in the crisis magazine about it and their field secretary, even at the agreement, was talking as if the public accommodations was the big thing.
And I guess it was for them.
But your position?
But then yeah, because if you're born here and then here, and you know what?
The Kennedy's invited Robert Kennedy and invited you to White House.
Yes. I think that was because I think we were having a conference with the governor in Baltimore,
but something happened when we out of town and about 200 blacks and 200, 300 whites almost came together on Ray Street.
And everybody got scared.
The guy standing in branch and Phil Savage, branch who, I don't know what about Savage,
the branch turned out to be FBI for them.
When I got back, they were all upset and died and died.
Oh, it's going to be a civil war and died and died.
And I thought, was it really that bad?
But anyhow, whatever happened, I don't know whether the press called Robert Kennedy.
They claimed that Robert Kennedy called there, but that started the whole meeting.
Now, they had been in a relationship between seeing that, and the White House through Galston,
and the whole Maria's father's, Sargent's father were friends.
And then the friend of my family that had been in civil rights division, the Maceo Hubbard,
but it had not gotten to that point.
And so they told us we had to come up there.
And of course, it may have been, because Galston tells me that there's stuff going on that we knew about our hair would have been white then.
But anyhow, I remember distinctly, and I thought, gee, was almost every cross-thera-fare from Cambridge to Washington,
there were police cars stationed and they turned us off.
So I thought gee, but then subsequent, subsequent conversations, they said that, you know, it was just simply too dangerous.
In fact, on that meeting, they had a woman at the White House that my uncle took me to what we thought was backfire.
Apparently, was a shot over a fighter.
And we kept on going because we said, gee, it's backfire.
But when I got back that night, because we went to visit some people in Washington, and I guess disappeared from some radar,
when I got back, the press was in my living room, and the word had gone out, we'd been killed.
Is that right?
Yeah.
And I had, you know, reflecting back now, I think, what?
But at that time, my old reaction was, that's crazy.
What do you want?
This was this going from all in Cambridge?
Cambridge, Washington and back, yes.
What were your strategies, mechanisms for dealing with all that pressure and fear?
I don't know. I think, I mean, I'm not saying that I was never afraid.
I don't know. I always depended that I always thought, well, if they get me, those people in Cambridge will get them.
And then I used to recite this thing from Quillenwood Cray, you know, if I'm pinned to, I'm paraphrased that.
If I'm pinned against the wall like a hole, let me not die like one.
And although I'm secular and the part of the wall walk through the shadow, I used to repeat that.
You went to jail for a couple of weeks in the spring of 1963.
Yeah.
And...
First of all, somebody arrested me in the army. I had to go over in the barracks instead.
Yeah. And did you get the army?
Well, the week, yes. Because I think Donna and my mother both were there.
And what happened was my mother could not believe that some little corner, Coca-Cola place, was not going to serve her.
They'd grown up in Cambridge. They'd come in some little sheep's store.
And so she was going to go to show that it could be done and got arrested.
Donna and the young people also got arrested. But they...
It was right after whatever happened and suddenly, and they were in jeans and stuff. They went in their school clothes.
So when they got in jail, they decided among themselves that they would go out, go home, put on jeans, and go lay in the theaters there.
Did not tell us. I thought, oh, there's no one with these children. Are they turning into Uncle Tom's?
And of course, by that time, the jail process, people were asking, you have kids 13 and 14, and what are you doing?
And so they were anxious to get them out and keep us. And they did that. When they laid in the theaters after they changed their clothes, the police went back and picked them up and beat them.
And the adult advisors on the street saw it and went back, house knocking on doors. They're killing our kids.
And then the whole town poured out. I think about 12 o'clock, and we kept thinking, what is this roar? It's this big roar.
And we got on our toes and peaked out to do the jail cells. And I said, I think there's people. And it was.
In the nightgowns and everything, just pouring this was way, way, way we should always say, don't go too far from the second world because we can't get out there, you know, and help you.
So don't, like that whole thing with Army, don't get too far ahead of your supply line. That's why I thought they were going to mess up and they're wrong, but anyhow.
And then they filled the tails. And then when Cambridge started asking Surrounder and Towns to take them, they wouldn't do it. No, we ain't going to have that mess over here.
And they eventually had to free some people in order to make space for other people. But that's, you know, that's when I think the entire town came together.
Yeah. Your trial would result in a one cent fine. When you tell that story?
Yes, the judge was laryd handy. And we went through the trial and testified. I was really surprised. I didn't know what he was going to do. But I think he was conflicted.
I'm not sure why. I know what the rumor is. But I think he formed a committee and we refused to come out of jail to be so thinking. But he did form a committee, you know, based on our demands.
So the rumor was afterwards that he, he for a while had to go in a rest. Tell him, I don't know whether that's true or not. But I think he was conflicted because that, that dissuessing charges of the penny fine was, and he did it very seriously. You know, we were like, what? What does this mean?
And of course, he gave me a five minute lecture on my position, my grandfather. What was I thinking about? What did I have to demonstrate about?
I wasn't Cambridge fine. And so on.
Can you recall the night when the citizens council brought George Wallace to town?
Yes, almost everybody up and down because black, white, priest, whatever came into Cambridge. Some of the snake people didn't want to march. But Wallace had been all over the state of Maryland.
And with some people in Cambridge backing him. The, I'm not sure that all of the articles about the fire department, but not only was it segregated, but they had been out in the black community and black folks that contributed to a $3,000 building thing.
And then they were told they couldn't come in. So that was a big and that Wallace would come and choose that place to do the speech.
It was like, you know, ten of us. And then they used that bag, what was it, CN2 or something? No, that's CN2 gas.
Yes, they used that gas. And the baby they talked about, the local doctor went and they didn't autopsy and boil them more.
I don't know whether it was actually true that the gas did not do it or whether because of the situation.
And we kept questioning that, but that's all we got. It was not, you know, two-junk gas. But that was, and I think, Gilston joked afterwards that the wind changed and the gas blew over on the other side of town.
And on the soldiers, but they had sent the autos as brother in there. Who's brother?
General Tos is brother. He was not in leadership because when they put us in the army trucks and I said to them, oh, you know, we want to talk to General Gilston.
And it's just a perfectly cold flight. Three or four times I thought, what the hell is wrong with them?
But I did not know that it was only the Tos guy there. And I think he was among other things besides being mean, just scared you death.
And that use of CN2 gas was reported the time to have been the first ever instance of the civilian use of that gas?
It may be the only time because except when Hillary Clinton made the mistake of apologizing to, oh, what's the guy's name? Oh, by them using it over there.
In Palestine, here.
But that night you were earlier looting to the fact that one elderly man and an infant died and it was believed that their contingents had been so seriously taken by the gas.
And they said people were crawling on the ground. They had taken some of us out. But it made us sick because the people they arrested with us had it in their clothes.
And when they took us over to Baltimore County, you know, you could smell it.
And then of course they didn't know what to do because they didn't know how to try us.
So there was all that after all this stuff went on.
Sure. Yeah.
Let's spend a few minutes talking about the March on Washington, which would be a very interesting day in so many respects.
Okay.
Let's take a quick look at personally the only one.
Okay. We're back after a short break.
I want to ask about March on Washington.
Okay.
I understand that a few weeks before the event, you were asked to come and participate.
And then some very interesting.
I don't think that was of the free will. I think somebody must have said, how can you do this?
I don't know who, but for a long time, let's add some more women to the program.
Probably.
And then on the day of the March on Washington, you had to think very carefully about what you would wear.
Oh, yes, because they call me and tell me not to wear jeans.
So then I went all across Eastern Shore and Pearl and looked what we weren't shopping in Cambridge.
We've shopped in Seoul for it by then.
Looking for something in denim, which isn't like today.
That was a skirt or a dress, but still would be, we call them dunger-reased.
Still be that material.
And finally, in one store found this skirt with the straps.
Then when I got there, also Snicken made us coordinators for organizing people of the Eastern Shore.
But I mean, Malcolm's right.
It seemed to me it was turning into a big party.
When a lot of us were out in the streets, you know, very threatened when you're going to have all this music and a picnic.
But any event, everybody seems to want to do it and doubt it, so we, in some people, came originally.
We only supplied the buses and packing house, you know, not one in Cambridge.
And so we went.
When I got to the March tent, there were these women there.
They had loads of parts, whatever, briefly talked.
And I said, then, when I got up and said, well, we're coming to the ladies room.
Oh, okay.
So I said then, waiting for them to come back.
And the meantime, somebody from Europe somewhere was doing a satellite thing.
I went and did that and came back.
I thought, gee, this is a long time.
And Bayer rust and popped up.
And he said, what are you doing here?
So I said, what do you mean, what are you doing here?
Well, I'm in your toilet.
No, he said, out there, it had marched.
I thought, oh!
So he took me through the crowds and took me to the stage.
And when we got there, it was either...
The two of them were sitting together.
I think it was...
You got Lena Horn?
It was Lena Horn, but I can't believe this.
The European dancer, and she went and despised the war.
She couldn't work over here.
We'll get it.
Yes.
I'll make it a problem to come back and see her now.
They said to me, as soon as they brought me to...
She said, they...
They removed your chair.
You need to go and customise about that.
So when I looked over chairs were filled.
And I said, what do you mean?
They took your chair.
Then I knew the whole thing was planned.
Not accident, or, you know, this just happened.
So I said, well, forget about it.
And I saw Robert Ming from Chicago,
and it was some legal thing that we had going on in Cambridge.
And I wanted to talk to him about...
I said, no, let me go into the back of these people here,
because I want to talk to this guy.
And that's what I did.
So then when they called me, I came from the back.
And I was going to tell people to sit there until they passed the Lord.
Don't leave town.
And as I said, hello, an NAACP guy.
That's nice to me.
Then they took me and Lena Horn,
because she had gotten roads of parks,
and was presenting her to the International Satellite and things.
Media.
And when I found that out, I went to help her,
because they would have been no Martin.
They've never had been roads of parks.
So I think they were annoyed at both of us.
And before Martin spoke, they put us in a taxi and sent us back to the hotel.
What was the rationale they gave for that?
They didn't want us to be crushed.
But they were crowds.
Yes.
Getting out.
Well, everybody else on the platform was okay.
How about your...
And then in the meantime, my daughter was out there being interviewed.
And she said, well, I don't understand this. It's a picnic.
So that was the position that people from Cambridge did.
Can you reflect a little bit about John Kennedy, Robert Kennedy?
You touched on that a little bit earlier.
But ultimately, how you're abused those two men and the...
I like Robert Kennedy.
I think there are probably three people.
I don't like to watch them on TV today, or it's difficult.
That's Adam, Robert Kennedy, Malcolm.
When you say Adam, you mean...
Powell.
Yes, okay.
Adam got that food into Cambridge at a lot of stuff.
And put it in the Cambridge.
Adam got that food into Cambridge.
Can you describe them?
Well, yes.
We had applied for the in-ghost and admitted that they needed food.
It was surplus food before it went into food stamps.
And Adam had arranged for that to go on.
The City Council in Cambridge and the governor said, no, nobody was starving.
Nobody needed food.
And he fought that fight.
And in fact, Cambridge was so whatever that the guard had to offer to distribute the food.
And then, white folks in the other side of town started calling us saying they had been threatened to be thrown off a welfare if they showed up at any of those sites where they were distributing it.
So the black men, you know, they...
Because they worked with them and stuff.
And they knew who needed food.
So they loaded up their vans and stuff and took it out to them.
To the white people?
Yeah.
That's in the middle of all this other stuff.
So you mentioned it.
Also, the union was trying to organize.
And in the middle of all the fight, blacks and whites met at a black rod and gun club to process the union here from...
I mean, it was here in New York.
The stuff they made in Cambridge went all over the country and were on that.
I can't think of the name.
You know, Parallel, isn't it?
Huh?
I don't work with someone.
Yeah, it's garment workers union, but I can't think of the robberweight, you're right.
That was in Parallel Company.
And they were paying lower wages for the same working.
Yes, to everybody.
So the issue was not jobs, but we all that work in this industry more better wages.
That was something of its sense.
The ironic, isn't it, that at the same time all of these tensions had divided Cambridge.
Yes.
That in the very near term you have black and white union groups working together.
Not near term, right in the middle of it.
Yeah, and trying to build some interracial union effort to achieve better side.
And they blocked them from meeting in any...
In their American, whatever their facilities were.
They would not let them meet.
You know what I mean?
The board on the broadened gun company, they can meet here if they're okay with it.
And yes, and I went to one meeting with some of the CNAC people.
And they, as luck they tell me happened in Appalachia when Snick went there,
they actually asked the black guys to voice their complaints to these people from New York.
Because they were afraid, I guess, of the people that control Cambridge.
Oh, I see, the white men.
Yes, the black guys.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, no, they didn't know.
And they asked some of the black guys to go.
Sure, yeah.
But they say that happened in Appalachia.
Some Snick people went there and they said, we will have to speak.
Not because they couldn't speak, but because...
Following through all this history, we haven't yet talked about Malcolm X.
And I know that that's an important part of this story and your sense of this history in Poland.
I had heard about Malcolm from people who left Cambridge and went into Army and were living in Philadelphia, Baltimore.
I had not heard him myself.
And I went and I didn't think very highly of Elijah, Muhammad, and whatever that was.
But anyhow, I went to Chicago.
Reverend Franklin was having this big thing with SCLC.
SCLC was trying to move into the cities.
And when I got there...
Detroit.
When I got there, several people said to me, you are in the wrong place.
And I said, well, they said, you know, Malcolm is going to be over at Albert Cleans Church, Reverend Cleans Church.
That's where you should be.
And I said, well, who is Reverend Cleans?
And I explained.
So I said, well, I really would like...
Yeah, no, I thought to myself, I'd like to hear him speak.
So I went over there and then they asked me up on the stage and then he spoke.
I thought, oh, I thought then he was going to leave...
Nation of Islam.
There was something, all he said, the honorable Elijah, Muhammad, the da da da, but it was something in the tone that I thought,
I don't think he's going to be there very long.
But in any event, the guy from Cambridge, Bob Pannett, who had a clinic there, he almost turned his head totally around.
He couldn't get over it.
And so that was my first, you know, personal meeting with Malcolm.
I'm sorry, Mr. Bennett, couldn't get over what exactly?
He couldn't get over Malcolm X. He just turned his head around.
This is a wealthy, upper middle class black and Detroit who has a medical clinic and daughter, daughter, came from Cambridge.
You know, just told full success.
And I don't think he was airing or anything like that, but he just never heard this before.
And he said, my God, I've never...
I think he talked over the next day and then he invited some of the SC, not, not, not some of the SCO, see people over to dinner.
And then after that, I don't remember too clearly.
I think we invited him to Cambridge when he was going to Africa.
And then at Act, because the men, we invited him there and he came.
I'm not really sure because he was doing the ballot and bullets thing.
And I thought that before the election, he should make a clear of Go boarder was running that it should not be ballots and he agreed.
The decision not be ballots, right?
Yes.
So, you know, we went through the, the, the act thing.
And then, actually, the night he was killed, I had been up to one of his things at the, um, Audubon.
But I was also supposed to be there the day that he was killed.
Can I hear it in the air? I couldn't believe that.
Is that right?
Yeah.
And the fact that actually we had been, my mother had agreed once that first bomb and the house happened.
She had a, in the parsnage in New Jersey, she had a almost totally complete third floor that his family could go over there and stay.
So you were going to, huh?
Your mother offered housing to.
And so we were going through arranging that and did he really need it because also before I left Cambridge, the, the, um,
I have a picture with the, uh, my Hamid speaks for Targolford from Baltimore.
He came to me and told me the Honourful Elijah, my Hamid, told me to tell you, you need to stay off of the stage with Malcolm X.
So I told him, you are a well-known Elijah, my Hamid has nothing to do with me.
But I think that was a warning.
It was after he was trying to, was the nation is, I'm trying to wiggle out of that chicken coming home to roost off.
But now this was like, what, six or seven months later, my time frames are sometimes off.
So no, we were trying so, so then, you know, that was like a shock.
I don't know what Maribol said about that because I can't get past, past 62.
You're referring to the Man of Maribol?
Yes.
I have something in there he sounds, I've heard him before my union had him but I think he's kind of patronizing.
I thought he was patronizing there talking about the civil rights.
We were all though he may have had his story, historical facts, right?
And I think he, I've sensed that in the book and I have my son in law, but I haven't been able to get past 62.
And now they tell me this someplace in the book, I don't know whether it's true or not,
where he says his biggest mistake was appearing on the stage with me.
Some review said that, but I think the, I just, I doubt very seriously if he's caught Malcolm.
The very fact that he says he reinvent himself.
I think reinvent is a poor, sure, a swirled, I think he grew.
I have to ask, so, so someone at the time observed of Malcolm X that his most significant mistake was appearing on the stage with you?
Yes, one of these reviews. I think I just, I think I just sent it to, to, I'm going to look in the book, so I have to book this, the page.
But the, can you, can you say a little bit more about that would have been a mistake because you were...
Oh, I guess I was worth, I was a bad figure for him to be on the stage.
Because you had become, you had become identified, how would you sum up how, how you had become known and recognized?
What did people understand you to represent by that time?
At the time, I don't know. I was just glad the press was there because they picked up the issues.
They learned while they came in, they didn't know what the hell was going on beginning.
And of course they were meeting with the ministries and the town fathers and stuff.
But the longer they stayed, they began to, that was true of the guard.
We thought the guard was there to keep us in. Why folks thought the guard was there to, I mean, we thought the, they thought the guard was there to protect us.
And we thought the guard was there to keep us in. And then they started fighting the guard and spitting on them and throwing things on.
Which made the guard, as Gelson said, probably didn't care one way or the other.
But they fell on the little ladies, the ladies in our community when they standing guard on the corner in the hot summer time,
would go out and carry on lemonade and stuff. You know, so these guys kind of got, oh, you know, these would be intriguing nicely.
Let's take a little break and then we'll come back.
Okay.
Ms. Tantra, let's do a final five or ten minutes.
Let's wrap up a little bit.
You had emerged as a figure recognized nationally, I think, across the movement as someone who really had, through her efforts and her position in the community,
through the strength of your local movement, had really emerged as a uniquely independent, independent movement leader.
And I'm interested in your thoughts about that and how you thought about managing your relationship with not only the folks you work with in Cambridge,
but all these national figures who reached or interacted with you in these different ways, oftentimes, with a lot of tension.
I think that's probably a good question, but I had been raised, I think, from my family, both parents and grandparents, to look at people and judge them not by titles,
or whatever surrounded them with that title, and for good or bad judge them.
So, I really did not have a kind of awe of what are normally important people.
And also, I think my independence came from the people I was representing, and their determination, because I always knew they were there,
and maintaining kind of a creative chaos for months.
And in balance there, that in the end, we should be able to achieve something, or else nothing is worthwhile.
And I think that's what happened. The guard had to come in and out from each county and rotate. They didn't always have jobs when they went back, the state was spending more and more money.
The Kennedys were representing themselves as life savers to Africa and emerging countries.
And here you have within an hour and a half or two hours, what is this, and what are you doing about it?
And I think a combination of that, and maybe, I think I didn't think that hadn't, but maybe now, because I was a woman, but they were, you know, there are other women in SNCC that,
and also, I have to say, with SNCC they let local people decide what, and who, and they did not interfere with it.
I think Foreman was a little upset when he asked me about Malcolm, but actually he couldn't order me to not have anything to do with Malcolm X.
Oh, yes, but the thing, do you think, you know, he's very, he's not nonviolent, he's very, yes, no, he called me.
And I said, okay, fine, you all have to be connected to him, just let us, you know, we'll do it.
But he didn't push it, he just, you know, that one phone call, that's why I was always amused at after SNCC met Malcolm, and they, you know, as when they had tried all this other stuff and moving it in another direction.
I sat in, I think it was Bird Marshall's office before his office, one day, while they waited to see what Roy, everybody, Roy Wilkins was going to say in doubt it died.
And then in the end, I, you know, I had to tell them they have nothing to do with this. They don't have the people in the street.
So for better or worse, you're going to have to deal here. And we're not members of the organization, and actually, even core who was known to be active, except for Brooklyn core, was not too happy with it.
I basically, I heard, call G once and tried to talk you into changing your position.
This is a guy that used to, what he used to visit on a weekend parties and cabries was sending me and my cousins out and give us a penny if we went to this store and bought three cigarettes out of the package.
No, he came down there and they, you know, they offered a job and did the job strength. What did they call it then for the Eastern Shore Merlin?
And talked to my mother, they were friends, and they were friends of his wife.
But, you know, that was not relevant. He may have been surprised, but Roy Wiley sat in my house almost a riot of rock-to-cold.
He ran out of coal for the car and coal for this, and coal for Washington.
But I think he had come in and out of Cambridge as a young man going to school with my uncles and cousins and had a relationship with his family.
I think they thought that that might have, and my mother, I think, was here following forward, but anyhow.
Because I had these children, I was getting to fours, you know, what, and she was going to have to support me.
But I said no.
I'm trying, gently, to lead you up to that point because you had a choice message one time that you conveyed to President Kennedy and I was worth remembering.
Through Macy, I hope it yes.
Whatever it was, I told him to Kennedy brothers, we'd go to hell, but now I don't remember what he was they wanted.
I think they did.
If I said before, that's probably what it is, but I can't.
I remember where I was sitting in my uncles. I was sitting on a step with the telephone.
If it's something we were either getting ready to do or...
Did you want to put a little Cambridge?
Yeah, oh yeah, no.
And it probably would have been, I think it probably would have been more people shot and killed if that...
Why can't I remember his first name? If the tall is guy, he was really Gelsen's boss.
Gelsen was at the teacher.
And he was there.
If he had been there over the guard, but through all that time, I think things may have been messier.
On balance, Gelsen managed to keep that.
Yes, I think...
I remember when I first saw him, I was with Savage and Branch at the City Council having a meeting.
He just walked in and sat down.
Go Savage and Branch jumped up and down. Who is this man? He has no business being here.
Instead of Gelsen getting upset or insulted, he just said, fine, I'll leave.
And I thought, oh, he must have a lot of power with somebody because he didn't do the ordinary thing.
What do you mean, I'm staying? And it proved that he did.
You mentioned earlier in the interview that...
I think you mentioned, was it Branch or Savage?
Was later a determinant of an FBI informant?
Branch.
That parent, Miss Perry Mitchell's papers must have that.
He...
Well, Branch, when the Swarthmore kids came into Cambridge with the kids from the other college,
and planted some kind of civil rights organization, and they had been from Swarthmore, Baton,
and then...
Oh, that was really stupid because I think he had been a detective in a store.
But anyhow, he started coming in and out of Cambridge, and he was connected also with the NCAP.
But he was really in and out of everything.
And when they...
Actually, the people that told me about it were those...
With the anti-war...
Oh, now I can't think of their names.
They broke into the media-pensive thing, FBI, Office,
Priests, and nuns, the brothers.
I can't think of their names.
That's okay.
And they write at the moment.
And then they sent me word that in the papers that they got,
that he had been reporting back and forth through that.
How did you...
Because he almost shot Stokely one night, who came through there, unannounced.
And we were...
And when I went downstairs, I found him there, you know, with the gun.
But we just thought that was accident because, you know, there were guns all over the house,
and case somebody came in.
What happened with Carmichael's visit?
Oh, he was just dropping in on his way to New York,
or somewhere from the side.
And it was about three o'clock in the morning.
He came up and rang the bell.
Branch was downstairs sleeping on the couch.
Well, the gun was stuck behind and got...
So he grabbed the gun and got up now.
Now, since I found out about his connection with FBI,
I don't know whether that was some fake thing,
or whether it was a natural instinct or fear or whatever.
But it was a little, you know, little upset for a five-minute.
Yeah, yeah.
How did you see the resolution to that very, very active phase,
6263 into 64 in Cambridge?
What was your sense of what you'd accomplished?
I thought we had accomplished what we wanted.
I have...
I may have made a mistake.
There was a space of time after I left that I didn't understand
why they were...
It seems like the SNCC people left there
went to the Latin City ahead of the demonstration.
And they were asking for help.
And I didn't...
In reading it in retrospect, I didn't understand it.
And I didn't understand what was going on.
But apparently, it rioted itself,
and they just segregated the schools.
And they...
It started a housing project and stuff.
What it seems to be...
I look back...
It seems to be like six or seven months
when something should have been happening.
And I just don't know whether that was incompetence or...
Or...
Or what.
But I did think that as it moved forward,
that it would make a difference.
In terms of white Cambridge,
I think maybe...
Some of it went extremely racist
to a Justice County County.
Elected Lemieux...
Elected...
Lemieux Chester on the county hands.
Um...
They...
They at some point, the man here at the orphan's court,
so they began to make steps
in some of their structures.
Um...
And then, of course, that desegregation
of the busing systems and stuff.
Now, as I said, when I went back the other day,
now they amazingly have a black woman mayor.
Her father was on my executive board.
In fact, in that picture with the gun,
where they were getting ready to stab me,
he's the guy who's back as to the camera.
That's when National Guardsman has a rifle in your place.
Yes, yeah.
And you're pushing it in?
Yes.
I think he was going to try and stab me from behind.
But anyhow...
And that was a time when...
when Gelton was trying to argue me out
of having a demonstration and these pow, pow, pow, pow.
I didn't know it was...
We both, I think, thought it was guns.
But it proved it was tear gas.
But it was in that excitement.
Yeah.
So...
Let me ask this.
What were your motives, all of your motives,
in moving to New York City, 65?
Oh, because my husband lived in New York.
I mean, the guy I married, the dude.
Well, we had signed the agreement.
There was... there was leadership left there.
And I had two girls that had to go to school and be raised.
I remember this was not a paid position.
This was not an organization in a sense of salaries and office
and secretaries and stuff.
All the weird people that volunteered for some of that stuff.
So this did not expend the rest of my life doing it.
And so that hopefully had accomplished something.
And if nothing else, the people found out that they could
at least fight against it.
They decided to.
Tell me, the last thing I want to ask about is the last question is,
that there was an event in Cambridge for you a few years ago.
And I'd love to have you just recall that experience.
Oh, you mean when they said...
Oh, I thought it was simply amazing.
It was beyond my expectations.
The people who arranged it were very young at that time.
I didn't know where the idea came from or why.
But it amazed me that the whole town was involved.
Not just that, I remember.
Oh, yeah, no, that's what I mean when I say the whole town was involved.
I didn't realize that when I accepted it.
But once I started on that day through this service,
I really overwhelmed me.
And as I said, when I got to the banquet at Elk's home that night.
And got up to make the speech.
I thought mainly probably from expo, and people and stuff.
I saw the mixed audience.
I thought, oh my god, I can't have to speak to everybody.
So then I just said to kind of make your stuff.
I don't even know what it was I said now.
But it was overwhelming.
And then the awards came from all kinds of people in government.
Which, you know, I did not expect.
And then of course, the new mayor had just been elected.
It was just like overwhelming.
I had been earlier, was that earlier?
The thing at Washington College.
I'm not certain of those dates.
I remember spec I'm not too.
But I was surprised at that.
And the only reason why I accepted that is because one,
it was on the East and Shore 2, did not ever, had not ever
remember hearing about it.
And because the president said he had learned about Cambridge,
by listening to Malcolm X's grassroots views.
So I thought that was interesting.
And it was.
But as I told Bertipson, if I had known they were there in the 60s,
we would have been down there.
A private, what is it, the fourth school in the country
of a class school or all right, on the East and Shore Mall?
I used to go to Chesterton with my cousin while he played poker
with Lloyd Price and stuff.
And the guy, all these bands and things would come through
and had no idea that anything like that existed,
it just did that.
And when I got there, I found that they give a certain percentage
of scholarships now to those kids that come out of high school
in Penn County.
Any final thoughts?
No, I think this country is going to hell in the hand basket,
but other than that.
What makes you discouraged?
I know there are many things that might be on that list.
Well, I think that there's extremely right wing and fastest
Supreme Court.
And I'm saying that after considering slavery and the position
on that.
But I think now that stuff they've gotten away with with blacks,
they're getting away with it every party of blacks and whites.
I don't think some whites, especially immigrants.
I just had an argument yesterday with a couple of my citizenship
class.
They said, why are they doing, you know, you better be aware
of what they're doing.
I think the Republicans are not just right wing Republicans.
I think they're fastest Republicans.
If they get away with this, you know, all people in this country
are going to have a time.
And I don't know.
I mean, I watch.
And I think it's because in Egypt, I still, all those people
I've missed, that rapport that I watch.
I don't understand why with some of this except for the T-Poli.
But I think they used to organize and parental was like,
that's snicked it.
And they let them get too far out there.
But there's no opposing entity.
Well, unless it's an academia, but I can't imagine just people
in the country.
Maybe they don't believe it.
Mr. Anjai, I'm very grateful for your sharing all this great
history and your perspective for the series.
And it's been a real pleasure and a privilege to be with you.
Thank you so much.
Oh, you're certainly welcome.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History
and Culture.